the first rule of bright Club is do not
talk about bright Club the second rule
of Pride Club is do not talk about
bright Club excuse me for breaking that
all-important first and second rule but
some stories are just too good too weird
and wild and borderline unbelievable to
pass up telling it had been an
exceptionally boring day at the SCP
Foundation the sort of boredom not even
his usual pranks had been able to break
up so Dr bright was unwinding with a
good old-fashioned movie night he
settled into his favorite overstuffed
beanbag chair sat down with a big bowl
of popcorn and pressed play on his first
flick of the night this one was a
recommendation from Dr clef a 90s film
called Fight Club he didn't pay too much
attention to the bit about the
nihilistic struggles of the modern
American but when the fighting scenes
started he couldn't help but get pumped
up look at all that punching the sight
of those guys standing in a circle
cheering each other on as they fist
fought in the dark basement they looked
Dr bright had seen more than enough why
would he need to watch the last hour of
the movie he turned off the TV and began
outlining a plan of his own when he
needed it most Fight Club had given him
the inspiration he so desperately wanted
it was also clear he Dr Jack Bright
would start his own Fight Club but with
an SCP Foundation twist but before he
could set his plan into motion he needed
to run it by the most logical person he
could think of Dr gears he called
knocking on the man's office door I'm
busy Jack what is it Dr gears looked up
from the stack of paperwork in front of
him I've been thinking what if I started
a Fight Club of my own here at the
foundation Dr gears sighed heavily that
is the worst idea I've heard all week
and yesterday you asked if we could
leash train scp-682 you sure I thought
would be a really cool idea no it's
terrible don't do it could you shut the
door when you leave Dr gears took a
large sip of black coffee and turned
back to his paperwork without another
word Dr bright was a little disappointed
that Dr gears wasn't on board with his
amazing plan but hey in this world some
people are true Visionaries and others
just can't wrap their minds around
Innovative new ideas it would have been
nice to have a numbers guy to help with
the basic ins and outs of running a
Fight Club but like all his best ideas
it seemed that he would just have to
handle everything himself gears would
thank him later when he saw firsthand
how completely awesome it was to pack a
room full of anomalies and make them
fight each other so now that he was
resigned to his role as a Maverick
setting out on this Grand Venture alone
it was time to recruit the best
anomalies he could find and assemble the
Ultimate Dream Team first he would need
a referee someone to keep the
competitors in line and make sure they
didn't break any of his rules of course
he'd also have to come up with more than
two rules first but he'd cross that
bridge when he got to it that was future
Jack's problem for now who would be
impartial enough fair and balanced
enough to keep everyone on their best
behavior a proverbial light bulb went
off over Dr Bright's head and he knew
just who to ask
scp-343 also known as God was sitting in
the canteen and enjoying a grilled
cheese sandwich when he turned to see Dr
bright looking at him with a kind of
beaming grin that said I need a favor oh
hello Jack what can I do for you 343
asked Dr Bryant gave him the pitch
including a few visual aids in the form
of posters he had hastily drawn
depicting various SCP battles he hope to
see take place on the final poster he
had drawn depiction of scp-343 wearing a
striped uniform and holding a whistle
keeping the piece in the ring so what do
you think Dr bright asked you're going
to go through with this whether I agree
to help or not aren't you God's side Dr
bright nodded enthusiastically all right
I'll participate I don't have anything
else going on today with the referee
officially on board Dr bright set out to
find his next recruit he popped in to
scp-049's containment cell where the
play doctor was working on reanimating a
cow's heart good day Dr bright the
plague doctor greeted him cheerfully you
look to be in good hand Dr bright
explained the fight club concept to him
and asked if he would like to join the
flight doctor shook his head I'm afraid
not my friend as a physician I took an
oath to do no harm and to participate in
such a club would be a violation of my
life's Mission however should you
require Dr
treat any injuries incurred during your
clubs activities I would be delighted to
offer you my services Dr bright was a
bit disappointed that he wouldn't get to
see the plague doctor bring his deadly
touch into a combat scenario but he
understood he accepted the doctor's
offer and move on to the next potential
member on his list he found scp-9999 the
Tickle Monster resting in its pen after
a hearty meal of chocolate pudding and
candied strawberries hiku delightedly at
the sight of him oozing over to nuzzle
his leg and give him a big hug he
immediately felt his mood left and it
gave him the extra boost he knew he'd
need to see this plan through to the end
he did his best to explain the notion of
a Fight Club to the slimy little friend
but he couldn't be sure if the Slime
creature actually understood or not
either way it was excited about the
attention and would be following Dr
bright around for the rest of the day
worst case scenario he supposed it could
provide a necessary morale boost to any
combatants that needed it he didn't have
great luck recruiting his first two
ideas so Dr bright decided to switch
gears a bit instead of talking to
anomalies with complex relationships to
violence or even an adversion to it
altogether he would reach out to a
creature that hated absolutely
everything in the world except for
violence
scp-682 was in its Acid Bath doing what
it did every single day seething with
rage against all living things hey there
you big beautiful lizard Dr bright
called as he opened the door to the
monster's cell before the creature could
say a single word he launched into his
pitch you like fighting don't you well
have I got an offer for you when he
finished he waited for 682's response
disgusting it hissed so I'll put you
down as a maybe then the creature
snapped its jaws at him in response and
he took that as his cue to leave it
would be enough for anyone else to get
discouraged but once Dr bright had an
idea he stuck to it at least until
something better came along but until he
thought of a more entertaining plan he
was all in on the SCP Fight Club
thankfully his next batch of potential
members were a lot more receptive to the
idea
scp-082 gave Dr bright an unsettlingly
enormous smile at the invitation
exclaiming perfect I was once a
heavyweight champion fighter you know
yes I won many trophies over the years I
was the very best in the sport perhaps
you've heard of Me John Sullivan the
Boston Strong Boy I thought your name
was Fernand Dr bright asked but oh after
ringing scp-662 the butler's handbell
the attached proper English butler
immediately manifested ready to attend
to any task yes sir Mr deed stood at
attention I need you to participate in a
very special Club Dr bright began it was
an offer he quite literally couldn't
refuse
scp-847 the mannequin was extremely
receptive to the idea at least Dr bright
was pretty sure she was she mostly
responded with a series of wordless
shrieks and jerky movements but she
seemed plenty ready for a good brawl
scp-2273 was a bit reluctant at first
insisting that combat is not a game and
you can't fathom the things I've seen on
the battlefield the men I held in my
arms as they drew their last breath but
after a bit of a spirited debate and the
promise that all the fighting would be
relatively light-hearted and not at all
like his time at War Alexi belatroff
finally agreed to join in on the fun are
we speaking of about a fisticuffs a
jaunty voice rang out Dr bright turned
to look for the source of the sound and
the voice shouted wait a moment there
old boy you're about to step on me he
looked down and found the person The
Voice belonged to a brightly colored sea
slug slamming his way across the floor
oh Lord Blackwood do you want to join my
Fight Club Dr bright asked indeed it
would be my pleasure I was a member of
many a private gentlemen's club in my
day and I find nothing keeps the blood
pumping in the body in Tip-Top shape
like a round of boxing I confess I've
been neglecting my fitness as of late
and this would be just the Shaker that
my routine demands thank you for your
invitation Dr bright wasn't exactly sure
how scp-1867 would be able to throw a
punch when he didn't have arms but he
wasn't about to question it never look a
gift slug in the mouth as they say so
far he had a giant cannibal a super
soldier from Another Universe a living
mannequin and a very Dapper sea slug
what's next before he even had a chance
to check his list Dr bright heard a
robotic voice coming from down the hall
it is I punchbot 5000 the ultimate
fighting robot now that was a perfect
candidate if there ever was one he
rounded the corner and found
scp-1370 there lying on its back kicking
its legs uselessly as it tried to climb
back onto its feet I have got the
perfect place for you to work out that
fighting Spirit punchbot he extended the
hand to help the robot up and then slap
the hand away down help me I can do it
myself it insisted and continued to
struggle for several more minutes before
it finally managed to climb back to an
upright position so with pesterbot on
board Dr bright could really see his
vision taking shape before his eyes he
followed the humming sound of a giant
sun lamp to the modified humanoid
containment chamber that housed the hero
no one was looking for but the hero Dr
Bryant truly needed and believed he
deserved
scp-2800 sat inside curled up in the
fetal position beneath the glow of his
lamp soaking in the Rays excuse me I'm
looking for cactus man the spiked Menace
Dr bride knocked on the door scp-2800
sprang into action scrambling to his
feet At The Mention Of His self-given
heroic moniker afternoon doc Cactus Man
rushed to the door opening it to let Dr
Brighton looking for someone to help you
crack a case take down some criminals
bust some baddies I'm the man for the
job the cactus man that is
scp-2800 kept talking but Dr bright
didn't really listen to what he was
saying all he was thinking about was how
amazing it would be to see those spikes
in action in a bare-knuckled brawl
luckily cactus man was so starved for
something to do for any way he could
feel useful that he jumped at the chance
to join in on the fun now Dr bright had
really enjoyed watching the small
portion of Fight Club that he had seen
before he got bored but there was one
thing he didn't like about the club
featured in the movie it was all male
that didn't seem fair to him why
shouldn't women get a chance to fight
too he was nothing if not a feminist
hell thanks to his body swapping
necklace he'd actually been a woman many
times so he decided to seek out a few
more female anomalies to recruit he
tossed some beef jerky to the dogs
outside of scp-953's containment cell to
calm them down and distract them from
his intrusion inside the polymorphic
humanoid was sitting quietly reading a
book and sipping a glass of plum wine
excuse me sorry to bother you Dr bright
spoke politely remembering that the last
person to be rude to the shape-shifting
woman wound up with his insides on the
outside I was wondering if you might
like to join me for some violence I know
it's one of your favorite things
silently deliberately she closed the
book finished her drink and gave him a
sharp toothy Smile as her fluffy Fox
tale stood on end with excitement next
Dr bright plugged his nose to avoid the
swampy smell of scp-811's enclosure
where she lounged in the water humming a
little song to herself she was more than
happy to come with Dr bright especially
when he offered her a tasty snack in the
form of a whole live chicken she was a
very food motivated gal and he could
respect that he knew he would get in
trouble for this next pick in his lineup
but Dr bright couldn't resist bringing
scp-029 the daughter of Shadows into the
fold notable for her extreme hostility
and pension for strangling people to
death he couldn't wait to watch her in
action up against some of his other
members Dr bright was finally ready to
put his fight club into action and he
herded his merry band of miscreants
towards the break room to get started
but wait I was forgetting something how
could he have been so foolish they would
be perfect quickly he's printed over to
scp-056's containment room and opened
the door he already knew what form it
would take on before he even saw it but
he was still delighted at the vision
that awaited him inside
scp-056 had transformed into the shape
of Brad Pitt as Tyler Durden in the
movie Fight Club a perfect handsome
fighting specimen ready for action would
you do me the honor of joining my of
course your pathetic little worm
scp-056 didn't let Dr bright even finish
his question this is my time to shine
out of my way it swept past him and out
the door walking toward the break room
with a confidence of a champion finally
it was time Dr bright dimmed the lights
in the break room moved all the
furniture off the floor and prepared for
the Bloodshed to begin he clapped his
hands together delightedly taking in the
sight of his brand new completely
perfect unofficial SCP Foundation Fight
Club listen up everyone
began the rules don't talk about bright
Club no weapons just fists or whatever
limbs you might have if you don't have
hands if your opponent Taps out or goes
limp fight is over and if it's your
first night here which is the case for
literally everyone in the room right now
you have to fight okay who's up first
before he could so much as select a pair
of Fighters to step into the center of
the room the polymorphic humanoid was
lunging at scp-056 with a shriek fangs
barred and Claws out she struck the
beautiful figure still in the shape of
1990s Brad Pitt and though the beautiful
person held their own they were unable
to stop the foxwoman from beating the
living hell out of their face I've had
enough of this
scp-056 stumbled to their feet gave a
honey huff and ran from the room the
polymorphic humanoid wiped some blood
from her beautiful face and feeling the
eyes of the room on her Shrugged I felt
like destroying Something Beautiful
okay Dr bright laughed nervously who's
up next the daughter of Shadows was
already strangling cactus man who was
fighting back by poking her with his
spikes defensively okay that's not
really in the spirit of the game a
little help here he looked over to God
who snapped his fingers and teleported
the two offending Fighters back to their
respective containment cells in spite of
his best efforts this was not quite
going to plan who would have thought
that putting a bunch of anomalous
creatures in a room together and telling
them to fight would be a bad idea
absolutely no one could have foreseen
this Tony Hill who's up for a round in
the ring with Lord Theodore Blackwood
the Slugs slid into the center of the
room waiting for a worthy opponent
silence fell over the room no one seemed
interested in facing off against such a
diminutive fighter come on now get your
dukes up old chaps the swamp woman
licked her lips salivating a bit at the
side of the slug but no one made a move
to engage him Dr bright had to do
something anything to get the energy
back in the room in a stroke of
inspiration he shoved scp-2430 The
Immortal Hitler clone into the center of
the room once I hit this guy huh
immediately every anomaly in the room
descended on the man punching and
hitting his mustache face with
everything they had now this was more
like it I did say the fight should be
one on one but what the hell this is
great suddenly the door to the break
room flew off its hinges with a crash as
someone kicked it open what is this a
voice boomed Dr Wright turned and his
stomach dropped at the side of
scp-076-2 able entering the room wearing
a menacing scowl engaging in Acts of
brutality without me fighting without me
he turned his Steely gaze onto the
Doctor Who Swallowed a lump of pure
Terror in his throat he hadn't seen Abel
much since well he reflexively covered
the amulet around his neck thinking of
the fateful day that his Consciousness
was sealed inside and his old body was
destroyed Abel brandished his bullied
weapon with a bellowing war cry I have
come to fight you all
um actually it's a no weapon situation
in here Dr bright started to say but
what one look from Abel shut him up
never mind it's fine do your thing Abel
began swinging his blade wildly slicing
massive gashes into the walls of the
room and chopping the microwave clean in
half watching the chaos unfold around
him God rubbed his chin thoughtfully
this doesn't seem great the entire room
was a blur of motion of Screams and
growls and grunts of efforts as everyone
inside descended into a flurry of
uncontrollable violence Abel cackled
wildly as he chopped off pesterbot's
head holding it up above him in a show
of vicious Glee Dr Wright collapsed to
his knees as he watched it all powerless
to stop a thing how is he supposed to
know that starting a fight club would
lead to an all-out Whirlwind of
Unstoppable Discord and violence that he
was creating a monster he could never
hope to quell it's not like this
happened in the movie this whole project
had ended up in absolute Mayhem suddenly
the chaos was broken up as a group of
armored mobile task force operatives
rushed into the room pulling everyone
apart and dragging them back to their
respective containment cells he
recognized their uniforms as belonging
to members of the Elite Mobile task
force the red right hand they cuffed Dr
bright me in dignity and brought him
before the o5 council for judgment you
absolute cretan your tiny-minded little
imbecile though 5-1 sneered I'd ask what
you were thinking but I already know the
answer you weren't what are you gonna do
to me Dr bright cowered before the power
of the council something that truly fits
the crime 05-1 smirk your movie
privileges have been officially revoked
until further notice now go check out
SCP Edition weirdest things on Amazon Dr
Bright's great idea and hilarious list
of things Dr bright is not allowed to do
for more wacky and wonderful incidents
from Dr bright